hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Al my neck ah now i
twerked my neck anyway we're playing the
forest and when we're doing when we're
playing the forces we're playing that
second level the one over here that was
the one with overly attached girlfriend
maybe this one has it too I don't really
know but it's a second app so I just
thought I'd give it a little try here
remember oh oh hey did I some oh I get
it
ah cuz I was getting gas and I was gonna
try to escape the first island but
apparently you can never escape which is
always a good thing and wait no it's the
opposite that it's a bad thing
oh yeah bad thing oh well I'm guessing
that the lady of the night
is gonna be back in full force haunting
me with her overly attached admits
don't see her yet pretty dark though so
I'm sure she's gonna sneak up on me any
moment what's in here another automatic
kill me button one of five
hey I'm collecting items now if you
watched the previous video if you didn't
it's in the description or it's in the
annotations if you watch the previous
video you know that this is kind of like
slender its slender ask I mean it's made
on the same engine oag kind of behaves
in the same manner probably means she's
nearby
this force kind of creeps me out
then again you know I don't see why a
dark forest with very little lighting
and a piss-poor excuse for a flashlight
wouldn't creep you out what whatever
and mysterious noises going off at
random times also creepy okay there's a
lot of sheds here that does not seem to
be items in all of them this one I don't
know the layout of the map so if I miss
a shed I am screwed I am very much in
the dead hopefully I can be skilled
enough also I might be going in a circle
I have no idea I might be I might be
just a big idiot here today I I think I
just went in a big circle I think I did
sprinting printing excuse me pardon oh
what's that oh what's that
Oh a Z are you out there baby come on
out what you gonna do what you gonna do
with all that junk all that junk inside
your trunk no no no can't stop thinking
about oh AG no no does that hurt wait I
thought I saw something down there
I saw something white that's for sure
whatever I'm going up on a hill I
probably won't see her close until I get
the second item like a nice little
bridge here is he gonna collapse also
where am I going am I going up to the
top of the mountain and if so why there
better be an item up there don't know
who I'm threatening with that but there
better be that's all I'm saying
hello another bridge am I going even
further up the mountain
rabidly let's run can't see any ten okay
ah there we are it's a shed but man that
was a long way to go for a short drink
well I still don't know that saying a
long way to go for a short drink up AHA
two of five Mystery's crystals so can I
just jump off the mountain here could I
do that by not gonna stop me is yeah hop
yeah like a fouls screw you and your
game mechanics they call me the exploit
actually back when I played World of
Warcraft before Cataclysm came out I was
a guy I loved to explore like on on
mountains where you couldn't go so I was
I was I was a mountain climber thought
up on Ironforge now blah blah blah blah
I don't play anymore but I did I did I
openly admit it I'm a recovering Wow
addict okay so I still don't see any
sign of her pretty I might just be
running in circles for all I know
because everything kind of looks the
same okay I hear sounds and here seems
to be a path up into the mountains again
hopefully it's not to the same location
seriously I'm gonna I'm like thinking
that she's gonna pop up behind me hi
honey
are you how was your day I enjoyed
watching you work come on best areas
Christo come on no I've only got two of
five it would be a shame to die this
early
okay all right no big deal no big deal
just a psycho psycho lady and the woods
was to kill aha number three number
three oh yeah
Oh Bosh's Hey look it's her hi
hello baby how you doing
I can't look at her that's right it's no
I can't stare at her what am I an idiot
yes yes
markiplier are you so silly uh-huh okay
so yep still there okay I'm just gonna
keep it running and if I went up the
mountain and then I fell down that
bridge there if I go under that bridge
that's where I need to go right right
where the last two sheds are I'll never
know why I'm gathering crystals in the
first place I'll never know I mean what
possible use could crystals have I just
got on this island how do I know they're
even gonna help me like if they summon
the demon lady
girlfriend I'm gonna kind of try to
avoid that okay that leads up the
mountain again I don't think I've been
up this way before hopefully maybe I can
beat this game but this is me we're
talking about so that is unlikely
unlikely
oh no I didn't getting kind of closer
getting kind of closer nope no crystal
run run run run run run run you silly
[ __ ] run from you oh no no and I'm back
to where I was if I hit the boat I'm
gonna be pissed I could have sworn that
I was going to completely oh wait a
minute
I think I am going back to the blowed no
maybe not I don't know anything about
what I'm doing I don't know anything so
excuse me while I fail yep there's the
boat
and now I've probably cornered myself hi
did you go I need to get back there I
need to go back that way oh come on yeah
you're gone are you behind me on the
lake somewhere where are you where did
you go huh now I'm concerned she's gonna
kill me
she's gonna rip my face off and wear it
so that we can always be together hello
hello I'm just gonna go see if I know
where but now where but no way I've been
that way I've been all of these ways
I've been every of the where how could I
be anywhere else I don't have any other
place to get the crystals I know I don't
even remember which way I want to get
where I was so how will I know where I'm
gonna be if I go that way in brings
closure oh you got your brains all over
me oh Jesus
Oh God oh fudge nutters I got for you
can f off jump down the mountain I'm a
survivor
I am the best that there ever was close
I am the best there ever was do Shire
hi hi sweetheart how you doing all right
okay so four or five ain't bad I
challenge any of you to do better
all right so same deals last time enough
time to go through it again so if you
could beat my high score of four before
Oh AG breeze down your neck good luck
but either way thank you guys so much
for watching hope you enjoyed it click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
[Music]